we're asked to add zero point eight two
two two five point six five so let me
rewrite this so and let me know when I
rewrite it I want to line up the decimal
so that we add the right place to the
right place and so we could write either
number first although I like to write
the larger number first so let's write
five point six five and remember the
important thing is that we line up the
decimal points so if we if we write zero
point eight two two so we line up the
decimal let me line up the decimal first
so I'll write the decimal right below
the other decimal and it is zero point
eight two two and now we are ready to
add we are ready to add so let's see
what's going on here so I like to start
in the smallest place that way the
carrying works out well so you might say
wait I need to add this mm to something
I don't see anything up here well you
could say there's just a zero thousands
right up here and then it makes it very
clear well zero thousandths plus mm is
going to be mm five hundredths plus two
hundredths is seven hundredths six
tenths plus eight tenths is fourteen
tenths well 14 tenths is the same thing
as four tens and one one another way of
thinking about is you're carrying the
one but really what you're saying is
look this is fourteen ten so I could
write that as four tens and a 1 and the
or ones place or what in the ones place
and you have 1 plus 5 is 6 and of course
you cannot forget the decimal the
decimal goes right there and this is six
point four seven two